[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas noches a todos
esto que ustedes ven acá puede ser
mortal esto que ustedes ven acá
es la causa principal de muchísimas
depresiones
esto que ustedes ven acá fábrica locuras
es la réplica de la interacción humana
que provoca conflictos que nunca se
resuelven
esto es una réplica de la dinámica entre
seres humanos basan en creencias basada
en mitos basada en bichos y no en hechos
voy a contarles una historia
una vez en mi consultorio
llegaron una pareja una pareja un
matrimonio convencional
ellos
ellos consultaban porque tenían un
problema en este caso de pareja bueno
ella consideraba que tenían un problema
el no tanto por eso empieza y dice lo
siguiente
empieza tu ya que tú eres la que
considera que tenemos un problema yo me
siento bien
y entonces
jalando aliento dice claro que tenemos
un problema si tenemos un problema grave
nuestra relación está por los suelos yo
estoy muy preocupada él de pronto dijo
que no iba a interrumpir interrumpe y
dice
exagerada
como base que tenemos un pero ahora
apenas tenemos problemitas
nombre y me voltea a ver y me dice
robert tú tienes que entender o por
favor fácil de entender
que los hombres somos diferentes a las
mujeres y que las mujeres tienden a
exagerar
vamos a hacer una pausa
pausa
aquí tenemos un primer supuesto
los hombres y las mujeres son diferentes
enormemente diferentes primer supuesto
que establece esta relación una
distancia
segundo supuesto ella considera que el
problema no es tan grave perdón y él
considera que el problema es muy grande
aquí empieza a ver una diferencia en
donde ella empieza a sufrir por encima
de
de pronto ya continúa y dice
bueno
la verdad es que sea grave o no yo me
siento muy maltratada en esta relación
yo considero que él ni me habla ni
siquiera conversamos bueno eso sí cuando
quieres relaciones si se lanza como una
que interrumpe es como así como así otra
vez volvemos a lo mismo tenemos tenemos
que explicarle a ella brother por favor
que nosotros los hombres somos más
animales más carnales y tenemos
necesidades más intensas
y entonces volvemos a ver otro supuesto
los hombres tienen necesidades más
intensas son más carnales que las
mujeres por lo tanto son más animales y
eso ella lo tiene que entender
continúe y haya un poquito desesperada
ya jalando aliento y dice
y entiendo que tengan necesidades pero
no entiendo por qué me tiene que
maltratar porque no podemos tener una
relación cordial o el bid pero fidel
ahora la víctima
es fácil victimizarse y entonces hace
una pausa y dice yo ya no puedo seguir
en esta situación si ella se quiere
divorciar cuando divorciamos firmamos
divorcio mañana yo llamo a chad hurley
era el abogado
yo voy a marchar y le digo que firmemos
se acabó esta situación y esto lo
terminamos de una vez y ya es bastante
asustada empieza a decir cómo va a ser
que vamos a terminar tan rápido la
verdad es que yo no puedo tolerar esto
ya me tienes harta
se queda
observándome y me dice
en la casa es peor
de punto
ella no puede contener sus lágrimas
y se echa a llorar
entonces
ella llora
la ignora
le dije a ella viene
que empezaríamos trabajando solamente
con ella y que después probablemente
trabajaríamos con él ella me voltea a
ver y se me queda viendo con una cara
como diciendo este imbécil no entendió
nada
y lo quiero matar mil veces
en cambio él se levanta y me dice
perfecto
me invita a un choque de puños de
despedida
y se va y no lo volveré a ver dentro de
un año después
esto que ustedes ven es muy fácil de
entender pero corrigen muchos errores
que hemos creído
la persona que está arriba se siente por
los cielos porque hay una persona que
está abajo que se siente por los suelos
ella sostiene en los miedos de él
por eso es que ella tiene mucho miedo y
él no tiene nada
quién está arriba parece que tiene toda
la seguridad del mundo
no duda de nada quién está abajo parece
que tiene toda la inseguridad del mundo
dura duda de todo
lo que ninguno de los dos imaginan es
que la inseguridad desde abajo
alimenta la seguridad del de arriba
el de arriba se siente muy seguro porque
el de abajo está muy inseguro
esta dinámica no ocurre sólo en
relaciones entre hombres y mujeres
puede ser un hombre con un hombre una
mujer con una mujer tampoco ocurre en
relaciones de pareja nada más puede
ocurrir en cualquier tipo de relaciones
porque porque la reacción de cada uno de
ellos no depende de su sexo ni de su
condición depende de su posición en la
dinámica
por eso esta dinámica puede ser entre un
jefe y un empleado
entre una madre y una hija entre un
padre y un hijo puede ser también entre
un líder y su seguidor puede ser entre
un candidato y su votante puede ser
entre
un esposo y su amante / un exnovio ex
novia
incluso puede ser entre un vendedor y su
comprador
esta dinámica ocurre en cualquier
relación basada en creencias basada en
mitos en cualquier relación que parte
de supuestos grupales
es decir para que una relación como ésta
se mantenga
ambos tienen que estar enfocados en el
otro y no en ellos mismos
ella está enfocada en él y está muy
angustiada para que él no se le caiga
encima y él está enfocado en ella y está
muy preocupado para que ella no se quite
intuir que si esta persona se quita se
caerá por lo tanto siente vértigo
cuando los seres humanos están
constantemente enfocados en otros
empiezan poco a poco olvidarse de sí
mismos y cuando no se olvida de sí mismo
empieza a caer en desgracia
y entonces necesita la desgracia de otro
para minimizar la suya
o pueden ser que su desgracia sea
utilizada por otro para sobreponerse a
la de él
la única forma que nosotros podemos
salir de estas dinámicas
es empezar a enfocarnos en uno mismo
como principal
sujeto de cambio dejar de enfocarse en
el otro cuando un ser humano empieza a
enfocarse en sí mismo como principal
motor de cambio deja de ver el mundo en
categorías ya no mira grupos de
individuos
deja de hablar en términos de los
hombres son las mujeres son los ricos
son los políticos son los empresarios
son los pobres son
empieza a entender que un ser humano es
lo que hace
y no se define de acuerdo al grupo al
que pertenece
solo así hasta quién va a dedicarse a lo
suyo
ella se recuerdan
se puso muy muy molesta cuando yo dije
que sólo trabajaría con ella y lo
dejamos afuera
y fue porque nunca imaginó que poco a
poco fuimos construyendo poco a poco
fuimos evaluando esas creencias y nos
preguntamos realmente si es cierto que
las diferencias entre hombres son tan
entre hombres y mujeres son tan
diferentes
poco a poco empezamos a cuestionar los
mitos con los que hemos crecido y empezó
a enfocarse en ella misma y dejó de
enfocarse en él
empezamos a construir sueños que pronto
empezaron a convertirse en acciones y
sus propósitos en convicciones
ella dejó de confiar en su suerte porque
poco a poco empezó a confiar en su mente
empezó a entender que el trabajo en ella
misma
en el trabajo que le daría el resultado
que tanto anhelaba
un día
un año después
y ella se sentaron frente a mí
de pronto el brother
no pudo contener sus lágrimas y se puso
a llorar
ella
tranquilamente adivinen qué hizo
lo calmó
[Música]